So, maybe the others aren't coming any more. That's also possible. Clouds and precipitation, Rome and white, probably quite a bit already.
So, just keep going. So I've already pulled up Windy. Namely the so-called program, because with that it's actually really well visible — especially for tomorrow — when, or rather at what altitude, clouds are likely to be present.
There too I again chose ICON-D2 for tomorrow. If you want to look for Sunday, then it's better to use the European one or the larger ICON with 13-km grid for clouds.
In any case, if for tomorrow you have very high clouds here, so Night Level 300, 300-hPa clouds — that's 9 km altitude — these are cirrus clouds coming in or already there, then the whole thing slides a bit.
Downwards to about 5000 metres there's cloud cover including light precipitation from 3 pm. And on Friday you can already see that the whole day will be bad with cirrus and high clouds combined with precipitation.
If we look at it on Meteo-Parapente, it looks pretty similar for tomorrow.
However, we now have a bit...
Precipitation is forecast — here from 5 pm light precipitation, very active cloud cover, but up there the cloud cover can still go to the appropriate altitudes.
So medium cloud cover here and slides down, very efficient cloud cover from 6 pm with significant precipitation.
You can see that here too, actually.
Here it's a bit harder to see.
In the background it's mostly greyer, but you can see there's cloud cover in there.
That's also very well visible.
In Wetter, from my point of view it's a bit less clear, but you can vaguely see that there's cloud cover in there.
From 11 am for example you can see the Grab is already in the clouds.
You can see that well from the hatching.
So the mountain peaks.
The mountain peaks are largely in the clouds there, already from 11 am.
If we then go to 5 pm — because precipitation is generally forecast — we have a bit out at 5 pm, it's not really showing precipitation for us yet.
Possibly something is coming out of the cloud, but the larger spots aren't quite there yet.
It's a bit under-stated.
There it already looks clearer.
So from 6 pm onwards, as a rule, they actually all agree that the first precipitation comes in then.
If we then sit here at SRV, then you can look at the cloud cover.
That's also, from my point of view, not so neatly laid out.
If you now just look at the low cloud.
Looking at the cloud cover, for tomorrow 1 pm it looks a bit different.
There you can already see a bit more.
You just have to know where we are.
And we're at this small kink now.
And then you can also perhaps see a bit more for your region.
Especially down there with the time axis, fly a bit further back.
And you see the low cloud cover, especially on the peaks, becomes much stronger.
But...
Personally I find, as far as that goes — so far on MeteoSwiss, where do I have that?
So the L on the H, these winds as such with the display were very good, clear, and I was happy with it.
As I said, you then have to check for your region how often it works out.
With cloud forecasts it sometimes fits very, very well and sometimes is also quite off.
So it's a bit to be taken with caution.
Especially abroad I've done very poorly.
Here in Switzerland it fits well more often.
But abroad it hasn't been so often that good that I have to say, yes, you can really rely on it often.
Precipitation we've actually already got included here too.
Precipitation we have but then also the option there at MeteoSwiss.
Further overview, map sources, I still find that a very good variant.
You can scroll in a bit more and then go forward in the time axis.
That doesn't go too far of course, but let's go there to 15, that's the hour.
There you see that the larger parts shift further.
I just want to take a quick look there.
Yes, that works well.
They're saying almost — for us it's still a bit.
Yes, that's for us too.
Because almost in the area of the clock, it doesn't go directly at us.
But around the 7th at us, one hour earlier or later — I wouldn't go down to the exact minute there.
But we're all in agreement that in the late evening...
...then precipitation comes in, and that in the morning until the late afternoon, precipitation actually stays away from us.
The Foehn brings us the whole thing a bit from the lead picture, as you also pass over here or here.
Yes, actually not until late evening then, when the Foehn really comes together.
That the Foehn then comes in, that then the precipitation begins.
So you can actually prepare quite well.
On top of that take the R-Active app, where the surface pressure charts —
not just the forecast like here, sorry,
that's just the pre-computed general situation.
When it actually does, yes.
So not just the pre-computed general situation, but also the actual state from the cross- and weather service.
I've put the link for that from the cross- and weather service in there for you.
With that you can also go forward a bit in the analysis and look at what's there.
And if we now look at that in the morning,
in the morning,
in the morning.
On Sunday you could take a look,
we do have the issue,
but it's also interesting,
let's see,
how the forecasts look.
Reorientation
European
goes through Sunday
there
for a wind at
3000 metres, and we see
that there
48 km/h northeast
is reported,
it's not necessarily
a good direction.
There's, above all, a decent
strength here.
At 2000 metres it will be significantly
less, but the question is
still — I assume
that you'd still
perhaps even 15 km/h
north
on the left at the launch site
and then it'll be
no longer that just from launching
it won't be that any more.
I don't even know whether Meteo
Parapente includes Sunday — if we
look there, it actually covers
the picture again a bit,
maybe
in terms of strength here also for sure another
10 km/h.
Often off there, but
still
maybe still 30 km/h
at 2500 metres
northeast, bad direction.
So let's assume
that Sunday too still
doesn't look so
promising.
I don't know if you
can see it well for Sunday.
I think,
the display, so 2000 is
mentioned anyway very strongly.
I also find it cool that
the area has 2500
metres. It's just loading
not so well for me right now.
But
presumably exactly
what's going to happen will happen,
widespread
30 km/h from behind.
I could still imagine that,
that that's more the case for us.
30 km/h from behind
and not from behind.
So from the current view
with alone then
matched up with the two unionists
you can actually say,
that Sunday will rather be difficult.
difficult.
Wind at 2000 metres,
I'm in the
Flügel-Hobby now in winter and summer.
That's better for me, because in winter
that hasn't really worked so well in the past.
really worked so well. And so
I actually take the reference
at the moment always 3.
And here at Berni's also cool,
the 200,000 metres.
And I assume
that that's roughly correct.
8 to 13 km/h
Meterjahr. That'll
presumably at the
launch site.
And then it'll be tricky,
to launch by yourself.
If you look at the sales zone there
you see that you
in winter not — that it
is also a bit better channelled.
The gust pulls through the northeast.
So from that point of view,
going in now on Sunday
presumably from the wind
the limiting factor.
If we go to the
forecast
surface-pressure chart from the German
Weather Service,
then on Sunday we have
air pressure-determining weather, Bise situation.
That goes from
the isobars here.
With the curvature there we have
a Bise situation.
Wind forecasts
now, what we have,
definitely.
It's not always like this, of course.
But if we now go along the isobars,
we see that there
we rather have east-north-easterly wind.
And that wakes up
definitely in the three forecasts.
So that's
quite also
a reason
for what fundamentally, I think,
ahead of the cloud cover here could be a good day.
There you have to of course with
winds always take the high fog
into consideration.
And there
you can just here on the
haystack of diagrams also go to
the high fog and say,
what its upper limit is.
And that'll on Sunday
presumably
get up to 1800 metres
go. That's very high.
That's presumably such a
day where the high fog even up to
us pulls in, gets pushed
in with the strong
Bise.
Could that now for Sunday
also be for us a
very limiting factor.
So it's possible that
above 1800 metres
it's very sunny
and below that you're
then stuck in the high fog.
I think if you try
to prepare a bit
with the various apps,
and also
compare. That's always very important
on the day itself. How was
the forecast? Did it
match? I've made the
experience now that certain ones
just like to show too much,
too much, especially too much
wind given, or just
are also on the pessimistic
side. But
ultimately that's for a
flier better than if it's calculated too good,
calculated too positively,
thought too optimistically.
And sure, you might more often
stand at the launch site and
actually have to decide
whether it's still good or bad.
From that point of view, you actually have to build up your
own experience.
What's also true for your location,
where you happen to be.
Just keep in mind abroad
or take as a tip,
Meta-Karabu works very,
very well. We had
in Albania, they're actually
all agreed that we'd have normal
cloud cover present
the whole day. Windy, I
looked at other charts,
that had forecast that.
Burner also had in Albania
complete cloud cover,
showed 8 eighths.
Only Meteo-Parapente gave us
a cloud base,
2000 metres, 200,000 metres
and ultimately we had
almost no cloud at all.
There you really have to see what
for you at the location
is the better tool
and then perhaps with two
maximum 3 apps work.
I'll set you up
the
voucher code.
Whoever wants can subscribe to Burner
now, take out the subscription.
You get 10 Francs
credited towards the relevant subscription.
As I said, you can
with Burner
pull extreme amounts of info
out.
There are also
very neat ones, aside from the
weather, that you for example
also
from abroad lots of
information, the strongly
in the country airports or
in all systems
still gives, I find
from the presentation already
incredibly good.
I find nothing else that
with a glance
so centrally so much information
puts out.
I wasn't a fan at the beginning
of it, but by now I'm
already convinced
that it's also a good thing,
and that's why there's the option,
with the voucher code, also
save 10 Francs,
if you want.
I'll link it in the project
afterwards,
and whoever
wants to ask again,
or also specifically again
has questions, can
of course write to me directly,
if he isn't quite sure
from what he could
pull up certain information,
about the individual app.
Or the whole thing
then later
on the homepage under the
R-Active section look up again.
I'll upload the presentation there.
Yes, I'd say,
that was it from my side.
Any questions?
That would actually be quite cool,
if anyone has questions.
Or was anything unclear,
too fast,
too little info?
Feel free to now,
write, or raise your hand,
or just turn on the microphone,
and ask the questions.
Thomas, you have a question, I think, right?
Yes, you, a question — namely,
how do you with the German Weather Service
now the potential
high fog upper limit, where did you
find that?
So,
there too I'll send you the link.
Yes, super, perfect.
Wonderful.
Because that's still good to save.
Wait a moment.
Those are simply data
from the German Weather Service.
Right, yes, any other questions?
Things like that too?
Of course welcome.
If anything is still unclear.
Okay, then I'd say,
your task is very clear.
Look tomorrow.
How did the forecasts
match, what we
looked at today?
Did it happen with the
strong Foehn? Did it happen
with the precipitation in the evening
between, let's say,
6, 7, 8 pm?
That's something you can tomorrow
compare. Maybe just
look. Sure, our station isn't
working at the moment, but the Grabmaschinen station
at 2500 metres, that's working.
There you can also see what wind
there is. That's 2500
metres. Then you can look, if that
is around 20 to 30
km/h wind, then
the forecast there has also
come true well. There it actually
matched up well too. So that's what
you can do tomorrow. And that's what I
recommend you for the future too,
also perhaps for days that aren't
flyable, that you simply look,
what forecast did you
make and what actually
happened. Because only that way can
you improve and learn and
remember, hey, that's very good,
that wasn't so good.
For our region
is one thing,
where I've noticed,
many also work with
MeteoBlue, but
that has now almost never
matched in our region for us.
So that's why you have to
gather your own experience,
if you work with it.
I personally am not a fan.
There too you have to pay a bit,
if you want to use certain applications
want. And that's why I have
stuck to the three I presented to you,
interested. Super.
Yes, if there really are now
no more questions, then
I thank you and I hope,
that that has helped you a bit
for the preparation, for the
forecast. It's not easy.
You have to dig into it
and just
gather experience. That's important.
Thanks very much for your time.
Thanks also. Have a good evening
still.
Bye.